- But I was in it early,
like in terms of just
being comfortable with it.
You know, I didn't-
- You didn't fear it.
You didn't think it was
gonna fuck your money up?
- No, I didn't.
But you know, at one point,
at one point the record
companies did gas me up.
(Gary laughing)
You know they did gas me up
and I was down there in
front of Congress like,
"Yo, I'm not sure this is good."
- Fuck Napster. (laughing)
- Fuck that.
Because I was gassed and understanding
that they were just trying
to hold onto some shit
that was gonna go away anyway.
(upbeat music)
- The Gary V Audio Experience.
All right, everybody,
as many of you know,
listening to this podcast,
I've been thinking about
doing more interviews.
And when I was thinking it through
and thinking about who do I wanna get on,
who have I not been able
to really chop with,
because you know, two planes in the night
everyone's moving fast.
This man came first to mind.
I hit him on DM, he said let's chop it up,
and a couple of weeks later, we are here
recording on a Saturday.
The legend, that is really the
only thing that comes to mind
when I get to say truly,
you know, I think these days
kid has one good game in high school
and they call him the goat and I laugh.
(both laughing)
But those hyperboles get thrown around
but being 45, growing up in Jersey,
for me LL Cool J is on a different status.
It's exciting to kinda grow up in life
when you're in the same
general age and reach of age
'cause you get to watch
the whole manifesto.
Thank you so much for doing the podcast.
How are you? How's your family?
First of all, before we get
into a bunch of different shit.
- My family's well, you
know, healthy, thankfully,
having a weird Thanksgiving,
I had to call some close friends
and tell them not this year.
We had to break with
tradition, which wasn't fun
but I think it was the right thing to do.
And we're good. You know what I mean?
How's yours? Everybody good on your end?
- Everybody's good. Let's go.
Everyone's good. Let's go right into it
'cause we don't have a lot of time
and I wanna get into a bunch of stuff.
So I was born in the Soviet Union
and when I moved to America,
we moved to Rego Park, Queens.
You know, those are old
stomping grounds for you.
When you think about your childhood,
forget about parenting
dynamics, family dynamics,
which are obviously
number one, two and three
for most people.
But I spend a lot of time
thinking about environment.
When I go there, when I
say things that weren't,
you know, obviously your
parents, your grandparents,
those are life situation,
but the person you're neighbors with,
the first kid that you
connect with in second grade,
when you think about your childhood,
the neighborhood, the
activities of the neighborhood,
or the serendipity of
classmates or teachers,
what comes to mind outside
of immediate family,
of things that shaped you?
- Well, what I think about my neighborhood
and the way I grew up,
it's a combination of a few things.
It is... (chuckles)
This is a really complicated answer.
I'm gonna give you the real-
- As you can tell, I wanna
go into the different stuff
that I think might bring people value
because there's so much
on wax and video of you,
and we'll go into that stuff.
But I like thinking about random shit,
and I was thinking about
this morning, I was like,
I'm just curious, I think about
Robbie Turner, Eric Godfrey,
I think about
Jersey culture was
just the outside, it
was the eighties, right?
Like it wasn't video games yet.
It wasn't computers and things like that.
They just always think
about how that shaped me,
the randomness of my neighborhood friends.
So I love those story.
- Yeah, my neighborhood
was really built around
there was only one dad on my whole block.
Well, it was two.
It was only really two
fathers in the households,
which was...
And my grandfather.
Which was...
That was one dynamic.
The other dynamic was a lot
of guys coming home from jail
and shit.
So the come home from jail thing.
- The fathers come from jail?
- No, not fathers, but kids.
- Got it. Kids.
Like 18 to 22?
- Maybe my age or a few years
older, coming home from jail.
It was a lot of people always-
Like that was a big part of growing up.
People would always come,
which incredibly enough
made me wanna be physically fit
because you see guys coming home-
- Jacked.
- Jacked. Benches in the yard, you know?
So there was that, right?
Then there was the hustlers.
You know, there was the idea of,
now mind you, I grew up in a book,
I mean a house full of books.
And my grandfather came over from Barbados
and you know, he was a
member of a Masonic lodge.
He was a really kind of evolved guy.
But then you go outside
and it's kinda like-
- Thoughtful, thoughtful?
Like a thoughtful guy?
- Very, very thoughtful, very,
kinda knew how to give you an-
He knew how to give you a-
It's like giving a cow enough pasture.
You give somebody so much freedom
that they can't hurt themselves.
It's like, if you have enough land
you can let your dog run wild.
You can let your cows just go crazy
because if it's safe, there's not.
So he would give me a lot of intellectual
and psychological freedom.
He didn't put a lot of...
They didn't handcuff me mentally.
You know what I mean?
So that made me curious and
it made me wanna search.
You know, I've always had
a searching personality
'cause curiosity can be passive,
it could turn into wonder
or you could turn and
it can become searching.
- And you feared to let him down?
- No.
No.
You know, it's funny.
(chuckles)
You know, my grandfather, when I was a kid
he used to call me a genius all the time.
He said, "You're a genius.
He's a genius. This kid's a genius."
All the time.
"This kid's a genius."
- You start believing it?
- Huh?
I don't know if I ever really believed it
but you definitely wanna
live up to those standards.
- It's a lot better than being heard
you're a fucking loser.
- 100%.
- And we both know people that
grew up in those environments
and everybody listening
right now, people know.
And I think a lot about parenting,
of how like tearing down buildings
or building up buildings,
and then the question is,
where's the line of delusion,
and do parents or grandparents
create ramifications
when you don't do genius shit?
- Well, see, I think with that part of it
the key is that
you can have great
aspirations, great visions,
great dreams, great goals,
but you also have to think strategically.
But then you also have
to think about tactically
what you're gonna do to get there.
And a lot of times, the
reason why people have
that big chasm that they can't get across,
is because they're not thinking about
how they're gonna-
Now look, you know, there's an old saying,
plans get shipwrecked by
the laughter of the gods.
But a lot of times people don't have that.
They don't take that step.
They don't take the steps
necessary to get to the greatness,
to get to the high level of success
which has a lot of pain,
a lot of frustration.
There's fear.
There's hecticness, there's
nervousness, there's anxiety.
You know what I mean?
A lot of times people don't-
They don't deal with that.
- Yes, I mean, people
want all the accolades
they don't want the shit
that comes along with it.
Which is why they don't get there
because they don't have
the stomach for it.
- 100%. 100%.
So my grandmother and grandfather
used to always tell me
if a task is once begun,
never leave it till it's done,
be that labor great or small,
do it well or not at all.
So what that did was it gave
me the spirit of completion
and intestinal fortitude
and stick-to-it-ness
You know what I mean?
Like sticking to shit.
- How old were you when
you thought you had a shot
to do something different, different?
- Eight.
- Great answer. Why?
Do you remember?
- I just was walking around.
I remember just walking in
front of my house and saying,
you know, just I'm eight years
old and I could do anything.
And I believed it.
- Who'd you look up to at that
point outside of your family,
whether grandfather or somebody,
like something out there,
was music already on the radar?
Oh yeah, I know this right?
Your grandfather had some
music, jazz or something, right?
- He had music.
- I know this.
- He was a jazz musician
and he played a lot of jazz records
even more than he would play-
- Music was always around.
But did you look up,
was sports on a pedestal,
acting, anybody in culture?
- Yeah, you know, Bruce Lee.
- Bruce Lee. That's a good one.
That makes sense.
- Bruce Lee.
Bruce Lee.
- That makes sense.
Your age group.
That makes a lot of sense. He was huge.
- He was huge. He was the man.
And it was like, you know, quite frankly
he was the only guy-
He wasn't white, so I
could kinda relate to him.
I'm like he's not black,
but he ain't white
so at least he's something.
He's a little tan, I
can kinda go with this.
You know what I mean?
I can make this work.
- A lot of people don't
realize how big those Kung Fu
and movies were because
there wasn't that many-
There wasn't cable and
those movies would play-
I even remember early, early eighties.
How old are you?
- I'm 52.
- So I'm 45. So seven years older.
So you were 14.
13, 14, 15, if I'm thinking about the year
when it hit my radar,
but I'm sure it was playing before then.
They would play on Saturday
at 11:00 A.M. on Channel 5.
- When I'm eight, nine, from
age around eight, nine, ten,
all the way up to maybe 15,
that was all martial arts during that era.
That was all like, you know
from the early seventies on
up to like, that was all.
I was a little baby, a baby boy
and I was all that martial art.
It was like martial arts craze.
It was like,
♪ everybody was Kung Fu fighting ♪
It was songs out.
- It was big.
- But the thing about it is
getting into martial arts,
like my grandfather
put me in martial arts,
I took seido karate
and years later I took some yi chuan,
and I took a little wing chun, and I-
- Were you good at it?
- A little bit, a little bit.
Yeah, growing up, my
grandfather got me into it
because they wanted me to...
They wanted it for discipline.
But the real reason is because
I wanted to play football
and my grandmother thought
football was too dangerous.
(Gary guffaws)
- Really?
- So she put me in karate.
So I could have a physical outlet
but not be getting my brain's shook.
- Is that why you needed to act?
Play a football player in a movie?
You needed to get that off?
- Without a doubt. Without a doubt.
100%. I had to live that.
I had to live that out.
I got to play in Dallas Stadium.
I know what it feels like.
I got to be out there.
- Did you grow up a football fan?
- 100%.
I grew up a Dallas Cowboys fan.
- Yeah, 'cause they were always on TV too.
- I grew up a Dallas Cowboys fan
but then obviously as I
matured I became a Giants fan.
You know what I'm saying?
Once I got at that point where
I could kinda make my own decisions.
'Cause my grandfather kinda
guided me to the Cowboys.
He was real funny too.
'Cause this is a guy
who came from the Bronx,
he's in Queens, but he likes the Yankees.
So I'm watching the Yankees
and everybody in my neighborhood
is like Mets fans and shit
but then, you know what I mean?
They're Jets fans, and
I'm liking the Giants.
It was crazy. You know what I mean?
- The Jets and Giants,
neither team made the
playoffs in the seventies.
So there's a lot of New York
people that kind of gravitated
towards the Cowboys, the
Steelers, the Raiders,
during that era.
- Yup.
- Which I never understand.
'Cause I love rooting for bad teams.
'Cause I love loyalty.
I love neighborhood.
I love eating shit.
But a lot of people don't want
their sports frustrating them
which I understand.
Like if sports is an outlet for your life
who the fuck needs more headaches?
You know, you're trying
to escape your headaches.
- Absolutely right, Gary,
and I understand the loyalty,
I really do, but it's just hard
to be loyal to a loser, man.
Like, you keep losing
- Bro. That's depressing me right now.
- Yeah, I'm tired of that.
- That's depressing me.
So let's talk about music.
When does that even hit your radar
as I'm gonna do music?
- When I was-
I started writing when I was
around 11 or around 12, 11, 12.
So at about 10, 11, there's
all the martial arts stuff
we talked about.
And then there's the music, right?
And hip hop is flooding the streets.
- Do you remember the
first time you understood
there was a different thing?
What was it?
Did they call-
The first time you heard
it, was it hip hop?
Did they use the term rap?
What was the term in that
very, do you remember?
- That's an interesting question.
Initially, I mean it was hip hop,
but we didn't really call it that.
It was more about rap music and rhyming.
You know what I'm saying?
- I remember beat boxing
- That's the human beat
boxing, but it was like rap.
It was like rap, you know what I'm saying?
- Yeah, rapping.
- Rapping. And then rhyming as well.
As we got more sophisticated
because you know the guys that I got with
we all thought about the couplets,
the content, the cadence,
you know, all of that.
And that's when it came
more about rhyming.
- What was the first hip
hop song that hit you hard?
- Well, it wasn't even-
Well, it was some of the
Cold Crush Brothers routines.
It wasn't even on wax. The tapes.
I was actually-
Because I used to go between
Queens and North Babylon,
you know what I'm saying?
Every year.
I lived in Queens, I lived in
North Babylon, Long Island.
Queens, North Babylon,
Queens, North Babylon.
- Because you were going between what?
- [LL] My mother and my grandmother's.
- Understood.
- But there was a lot of foster kids
in the house next door
to me, in North Babylon.
- You would go back and forth,
or you would spend the
summer, or how did you do it?
- No, no, no, no. I would
literally all of the above.
I would go to school back and forth
and summers back and forth
and be back and forth
during the summer, and like-
- Hard or easy?
- Hard.
Like literally every other year.
I think one year-
- And was that was hard?
And was that hard for
you or do you think you-
Or at the time hard, and now you're like,
"Oh, that's why I can adjust to shit."
Was it kinda just, it's all you knew
and it's just, that's what it is,
and didn't really think twice?
- Well, it was...
- Did you enjoy it?
Did you like coming back and
like it was kinda interesting?
- It wasn't even that
complicated, it was just, up Todd-
- [Gary] It was life.
- No, Todd's a pain in the ass
so he's gonna go to Long Island this year.
Up, okay. He's good, he's good.
Oh, he's being a pain in the ass,
now let's send him back to Queens.
Oh.
- Any time that you would move
into dangerous zone, they thought a reset.
- Reset. They would hit me with the reset.
(both laughing)
- Do you think now,
do you think now that enabled-
If I said to you, what
did you gain out of that?
Maybe there's nothing.
Maybe there's a ton.
- A lot.
- I just-
Yeah, I believe in-
I think adversity-
- It schools ya.
- Go ahead.
- It gave me exposure, right?
Because the first time
I walked in a classroom
in Long Island, you
know, you gotta remember
I'm going from a school that's
I would say 99.99% black.
Other than my friend Richie who's Jewish,
who was like my-
who's like eight, nine years old,
who's my Jewish friend,
everybody's black.
I got one Jewish friend
and everybody's black
and Richie-
- Richie had it.
- He doesn't even go to my school.
Richie doesn't even go to my school.
Richie is a family friend
because my aunt is a schoolteacher
and her best friend, and Lynn,
and so me and Richie are cool.
So other than Richie, it's all black.
But then when I go to Long Island
I walk in the classroom,
it's the exact opposite.
Or the inverse.
Everybody's white.
And I'm like the one,
there's one black kid.
And I walk in and I'm the black kid.
And maybe there's another one.
And it was like, I remember my
eyes jumping out of my head,
but what it did was it exposed
me to different people.
Because you know,
you go to Long Island at that time,
you had a lot of Italians
coming from Brooklyn
moving to Long Island.
You know what I'm saying?
So you're meeting, so I
had like a Italian friend
and then you kinda find out
also just Irish friends,
but then you find out
about the racial dynamics
that I didn't know existed
when I was in Queens.
You know what I mean?
So that was.
- Did it come at you hard in Long Island?
Or did it come in medium,
or you would just say subtle
'cause people were cool like that?
- It's subtle. It's subtle.
You're coming, you know, it's subtle,
you know, two kids will be talking
and you'll walk in on them,
and they'll be saying something
they shouldn't be saying.
They'll be saying it, you'll
catch them saying something
they shouldn't be saying and
then they get quiet, you know?
But it wasn't like...
- Atrocious.
- No, it wasn't atrocious, man,
because New York is funny like that.
- [Gary] Yeah I agree with this.
- New York is funny in the sense that,
you know, and Jersey for that matter too,
in the sense that, yes there's a lot of-
- There's racism, but it's so-
- There's also jokes.
There's also a rivalry and a fun.
It's different in New
York. You know what I mean?
- I know exactly what you mean. I'm 45.
Like things weren't as politically correct
so there was-
- Exactly.
- I remember, people
would make racial jokes
across the board.
I mean, I caught a very weird time
because I was Russian when
the USSR was the evil enemy.
So I got real heat because
we were in the cold war,
kind of like kids after 9/11
that were from the Middle East.
Russia shot down a plane in third grade,
shot down a commercial plane,
and literally my class just
decided not to talk to me
for the week.
- Wow.
- Like we were the enemy.
And so I don't talk about it a whole lot
because it's out of context now,
people don't understand.
But like 1982, '83, '84,
go watch Rocky.
Like Russia was the enemy and people,
I mean, people called me spy every day.
- They called you a spy?
- Everyday, like, you're spying on us.
People-
- Hilarious.
- You know what's funny,
people fought a lot.
I think about fighting a lot.
I think fighting is different now.
I feel like it's extremes,
it's either no fighting going
on in the suburbs over there,
or extreme shit.
And every weekday on my Instagram,
seeing something that breaks my heart.
But when I-
I mean, I was in a lot of fights.
Kids were always fighting.
There was a lot of fights.
- I definitely grew up.
I grew up in the knuckle game, heavy.
You know, that's all I did growing up.
There was a lot of knuckle games.
- You liked it?
- No, I didn't like it per se.
But you know, when I was younger,
I was slim and I had that kinda face that
you wanna try to test.
- It was too pretty?
- I don't know, pretty, but,
they just-
- It's still pretty.
- I wasn't like grrr, you know,
I didn't have that look, so they weren't-
- You didn't seem scary.
So they thought they could come up on you.
- So I used to have to put some up,
put some of this on them.
(fist smacking)
- Do you remember what,
let's call it from six to 16,
the best feeling in the fight, and the-
Let's talk about stories
that people don't know.
Like, I'll give you mine.
In second grade, there was
a kid named Odette Weinstock
who came from Israel and just
decided that we were rivals.
We fought three times between
second and sixth grade
and it culminated after school
with literally a hundred people watching,
'cause he caught me earlier in the day,
pushed me into the locker,
and got on top of me.
And that was it, they broke
it up, we went to detention.
But at lunch, I just
hear the whole lunch room
in sixth grade, saying,
Odette beat up Gary,
and I was like, man,
I can't, this I can't.
This can't be my reputation.
We just got to junior high.
And I walked up to him,
literally like fucking eighties
movies shit, and was like,
"Let's fight at Marcos's house."
'Cause that was the hill.
(LL laughing)
Big shout out to Marcos,
if you're watching,
please email me.
Marcos's house, where
the ice cream truck was,
and literally there
was hundreds of people.
We fought and he was actually winning,
and I would argue that I got lucky slash
I just refused to go down like that.
He was on top of me, kind
of ready to win the fight
and I kept rocking and I got him off,
and as we were both on the ground,
I had the leverage and I
kicked him so hard in the face,
his face exploded, bleeding everywhere.
We kinda both stood up off the kick
and he just started crying and ran away.
And for the next 48 hours
was the greatest moment of my life.
(LL laughing)
But earlier that morning was probably the-
'cause of that micro,
I'll call it a micro loss,
'cause it's some bullshit,
we didn't even get into it,
but he definitely pushed me
from behind on some sucker shit,
and then he sat on top of
me, and they broke it up
and I didn't really have any offense.
So what about for you, six to 16,
best moment in a fight, worst moment.
'Cause I've never had
- Worst moment would probably be...
- Let's give it (muffled)
Have a good moment. You're
gonna call the bad and be like-
- Oh, this dude, I had a
fight with this dude, Mark.
- You know Mark's last name?
- I don't know his last name.
- Damn!
You know what I love about the world now?
If you knew his last name
and you shout him out,
it's like his nephew will be like, "Yo!"
- I don't know his last name.
I had a fight with Mark,
but he liked the girl
that I was friends with.
I liked her too, but
I was really a friend,
but I did like her.
The worst thing, and here
was the worst thing about it.
Me and him, and this is
the honest to God truth,
me and him were in high
school, I was a freshman,
we fought in the basement by ourselves.
(Gary laughing)
Yo, listen, I kicked his ass,
but got a mark on my face
and everybody thought he whipped my ass.
- [Gary] Damn.
(LL laughing)
I really punished his ass.
- Listen, explain to me
how you guys fought solo
in the basement of a house.
- No, no. In the basement
of the high school.
- Oh.
- In the high school.
I saw him.
- Okay, that's some real shit.
- I saw him and we was
talking, something happened,
one thing, and we went down a back step
and we was just down
somewhere in the high school
where there wasn't people
and we got into a fight,
and I was kicking him in the stomach.
I got him, it was a good fight.
I tightened him up real nice.
But however it worked out,
it was like I was
punching him in his head.
How it worked out is-
- You earned a scratch.
- He kinda scratched me, I had a welt,
'cause I'm a little fair,
so I had a little welt.
And then after, we sitting
in the principal's office
'cause security broke it up,
we down in the principal's
office, I'm like,
"Yeah. Yeah."
And then a dude walks in
and he's like, "Yeah."
Another guy walks in and
he's like, "Yo, what's up?"
I said, "Yeah, man, I just
had to whoop his ass."
He said, "Look at you,
you're the one with the
marks on your face,"
and walked away.
I'm like, "Oh no."
So the whole neighborhood,
like, it was crazy.
That was the craziest one.
- What was the best?
- The best one had to be like,
this is kind of a long story.
And it's gonna sound a little crazy.
But I was in Red Lobster with my friends.
We was eating and this
guy kept staring at me.
So, he stared at me for so long
that finally I walked over
to his table and said,
"Yo, you gotta get out of the restaurant."
- How old were you?
- I must've been, I might've
been a little older than 16.
I had to be a little older than 16,
but it memorable.
- But wait, you already
we're in your music career?
- Yeah. I was already making music.
'Cause remember I made
my first song at 16.
- That's right. That's why I know it.
- So with the guy, with
with Mark, I was 14.
I was about 14 with Mark.
This one, I was a little
older. I wanna say 18.
I wanna say 18.
- So you were already, I mean,
'cause you hit fast and hard,
so you wouldn't know, know.
- Remember there's no social
media. It's a little different.
- I remember.
- you know what I mean?
So, I said you gotta leave,
and he was driving me crazy.
And maybe I was a little foul for that.
So he left.
I actually kicked him
out of the restaurant
and went back and finished my food.
So then me and my friends
we driving down the block
towards my house, and a guy comes
and he's trying to pull us up,
get over here, get over
here, get over here.
He finally like, you know,
I pull over and he's like,
"Yo, you tried to rob my friend."
I'm like, "Rob, your friend?
Do you know what I do? Rob your friend?
You think I tried to rob-"
We ended up getting in a fight.
I said, "What, you wanna fight?"
He thought he was gonna
take up for his man
and he ended up catching an ass whipping.
- Aha. Let's segue.
- So that was a funny moment.
- How do you think you would have done
in this modern music world?
SoundCloud, Instagram,
knowing your personality.
Obviously you had tenacity because-
- [LL] I would have done phenomenal.
- I believe that.
- Phenomenal.
- I'm just curious because obviously-
- I would've just, you
know, if that was my thing,
I would've just been rapping
on every Instagram page
and every SoundCloud, like every moment,
every time you turn on the camera,
you would see me doing something.
- You know, it's funny
because I believe in volume
and I talk a lot about
putting out a lot of stuff,
and I know a lot about your career
'cause you were so in my pocket,
you sent your demo everywhere.
Def Jam was like, right?
- I sent it to Sugar Hill.
I sent it to Enjoy, I
sent it to Tommy Boy.
The demo I sent to Def Jam Productions
'cause it wasn't a label yet,
Ad-Rock of the Beastie Boys heard it,
he played it for Rick, and
that's how I got my break.
And then Def Jam, the label, was formed.
- After.
- [LL] After.
- Because I know you and Beastie
Boys gave them that clout
to get to the next level.
- That's true, and Rick Rubin's
talent, Russell's vision.
I mean, yeah.
- That was gonna happen anyway.
You just two happened too.
So how does it feel?
I think, you know, it's funny.
I know that it happened for me later,
it was different timing,
but I know when I'm 70,
there'll be documentaries,
there'll be things that talk about
social media's early days.
And I know I'm gonna get flavor from that,
and so that's gonna happen for me later.
Hip hop, you were very
young, you were early,
and you're still an
extremely young man now,
but you're getting Kennedy Awards,
you're in the hall of
fame, you're a real OG,
and it's incredible to
live and be a hall of famer
in something that you were there early,
and it's at the scale that it's at now.
You know, I think about the NBA,
it's not that old of a league,
I think about Bill Russell, thinking about
not sold out stadiums,
like no TV,
and now like what it is.
How does it feel to be at
such a pedestal as an OG
in something that is one of
the most important things.
Hip hop's one of the most
important things in the world.
- Well, it feels, look,
I feel amazing because
by the grace of God and hard
work and the grace of God,
I figured out how to
keep doing what I love.
I didn't have to get off the
train and watch it drive away.
Or watch it pull away.
- You also evolved.
- Yeah.
So that makes a big difference.
It's not like-
- You're not sitting on the couch
and saying back in '84 this is, you know,
you mean it's enjoyable
but it's almost like you
can't even smell that rose
because you're still, so active.
- I'm so active and I've expanded my life
to an extent that I'm still
so on the grind and so heavy
and so deep in what I'm doing.
Look, there's a thing
called the Lindy effect.
And the Lindy effect is basically
things that have been
around will be around.
So it's like Shakespeare.
Like eating with a knife and fork.
Wearing a pair of pants, a baseball cap.
These things have been around
for a long, long, long time
and that bodes well for the future.
You know, when I was a little kid
I always called it
stretching the bubble gum
and then putting another
piece of bubble gum
directly in the center before it pops.
And so I just keep going after my dreams.
I feel good seeing what's going on
but I feel like I'm in a
position where I could,
if I decide, yo, LL Cool J
is coming out with an album,
I know it's gonna get a look.
I can't tell you it's gonna
be a commercial success.
I can't make those kinds of predictions.
I can't talk tough.
But I can tell you if I say, yo,
if I dropped an album tomorrow,
people are gonna listen to it.
And I mean, that's the best
thing you could do for yourself
as an artist, right?
- Have you ever been in your
life, in the last 15 years,
'cause again, you've been
doing incredible things
in Hollywood, in acting,
and I'm sure a million other
things we can get into,
I always wonder this, at any point,
'cause listen, I love
how you answered that,
you're aware that you're not
in the white hot moment of,
I'm gonna put out an album
and it's YoungBoy NBA numbers,
you know, like, you know, you know.
- I know where I'm at.
- Do you ever, have you ever,
in the last 12 or 15 years,
I'm gonna just use that timeframe,
said, have you wanted that feeling again,
of being in the white
hottest of the hot moment
or you feel like you've
fulfilled or you were fulfilled,
you went and put that attention elsewhere,
and now once in a while, you're like,
Yo, let me grab one of
these fucking hot kids
and do a collab with them
just for one more tape.
And by the way, I talk about this a lot.
I talk to a lot of youngsters
and I'm like, yo, you should do something-
You know, you never-
They're like, I was talking about OGs,
I'm like, you should do
something with Diana Ross.
You should do something
with Stevie Wonder.
And I'm like in the South
side of Atlanta in a studio
and they don't even know,
like, what the fuck are you talking about?
Like, you never know
when one of the greats
is just sitting in their mansion
saying, you know what, fuck it,
for six more months, I
just wanna taste again
what I tasted in '89,
what I tasted in '74,
what I tasted in '62.
I think about that shit
- Well, it's art, right?
- Yeah, go ahead.
- Go ahead, go ahead.
- I've never asked the OG,
I always tell the kids,
I'm like, yo, cool that you've
got some heat right now,
but do something that's just gonna make
your grandmother smile.
'Cause I always think an OG, a legend is,
you know, if you ask 30 of
them, one's ready to do it,
and they're just cool to have,
but I've never asked a
legend on the other side,
have you in the last decade said,
man, I might really wanna go
uncomfortably contemporary
and I might want to do
something with Da Baby
or Meg Thee Stallion, to do that.
Or does that just never cross your mind?
- You know what,
like the reality is I would definitely
consider working with a
young act and with a new act.
I don't see any reason to
remove myself from that.
I'm not like one of these OGs
that sits around mad about-
- And for me, and I'm sorry to interrupt,
and for me, and for a
lot of people listening,
if I woke up and saw
YoungBoy and LL did a track,
I'd loop, my brain would break.
I think that
those kinds of combos,
like Gaga and Tony Bennett
made me smile.
- Yeah. Yeah.
I think, look, man, you know there's acts,
there's all kinda cool acts out there.
And if it's organic and if
we can find something that
we feel great about,
that we write together,
or somebody writes a chorus that we feel,
and a track that really brings
it out and makes it special,
why not?
I don't need to,
I'm not allergic to the new shit.
I'm not allergic to what's
happening in contemporary.
What's contemporary.
That's not a problem for me.
I enjoy listening to new
acts and young artists
and listen to them bridge the
gap, you know what I'm saying?
Like a prime example,
like Meek Mill just dropped
that record with Lil' Durk.
I'm playing that on my
channel, Rock the Bells,
'cause I think it's dope.
And it's got a lot of melody in it.
You know what I'm saying?
It's not even like Meek is
doing his normal spitting,
you know, rapid fire spitting.
It's real melodic.
But I liked the video, I like the song.
I'm putting it in Breaking Bells.
So it's like, for me, whether
it's from a Billie Eilish,
all the way to a
Da Baby, to a Lil' Baby,
like with the moment of truth.
I pay attention.
I loved the record he
did about the protest.
I thought that shit was hot.
I like Da Baby's performance
when he was on the awards.
When he was performing
with the knee on his neck.
I pay attention to what's
going on in the world
and what's going on in our culture.
I'm not a guy that's just
sitting up in a big house.
- Saying been there.
- Disinterested.
- Let's talk about that.
Let's talk about the technology side.
When did the internet,
when did you get excited
or when did it hit your
radar going way back to
AOL or Myspace,
when did you first kind of,
not necessarily know about it,
but when, maybe even
Napster, given your career,
what's the early internet LL stories,
of like, I thought it was
bullshit, I didn't like it,
I was mad at Napster, I
got excited about Napster,
Myspace was popping,
I didn't take it serious until Twitter.
Talk to me about your last 20 years
on the tech culture game.
- Yeah, well, for me it was you know,
Quincy Jones gave me a book,
"The Road Ahead," by Bill Gates
when that came out.
And I guess that was in
the late nineties maybe,
right before 2000, like in that
window, somewhere in there.
And so that kind of piqued my interest.
I thought Limewire,
you know, when Limewire came out,
I was really curious about that
and was like kinda trying to figure out,
searching for music.
I actually adopted and kinda
adapted to the internet
pretty quickly
in terms of the idea of it.
I didn't necessarily dive in as a user
but I was in it early,
in terms of just being
comfortable with it.
- You didn't fear it?
You didn't think it was
gonna fuck your money up.
- No, I didn't.
But you know, at one point,
at one point the record
companies did gas me up.
(Gary laughing)
They did gas me up
and I was down there in
front of Congress, like,
"Yo, I'm not sure this is good"
- Fuck Napster.
- Fuck that.
Because I was gassed up
and understanding
that they were just trying
to hold on to some shit
that was gonna go away, anyway.
They was trying to hold
on to a business model
that was no longer viable.
You know what I'm saying?
- Gotta go through it.
All right, I get it.
- But really quickly,
I was all the way in.
And then, you know, I had a Myspace page,
you know what I'm saying?
I had a little Myspace
page. I was into that.
You know, was there early for Instagram.
Didn't jump on it in terms of use
but right when Instagram
started, I was there.
- Are you on TikTok right now?
- I do have a TikTok,
but I only watch shit.
I don't really, I haven't
done anything on it.
- It's entertaining, right?
- Come on, man. It's unbelievable.
I know you got a TikTok.
I often come down and
check yours out as well,
and I go on TikTok, people dancing,
I saw a mother and a daughter
climbing a doorframe exercising
to "It's Tricky" by Run-DMC,
did you see that?
- I did.
- You know what I mean?
So yeah, I'm on TikTok
which I need to get more active on it.
Look, I'm all about, like I was on,
for the five minutes it was out,
what was the one, Periscope was it?
I was on that one,
that for five minutes that was out.
You know, all of them, all of them.
Facebook, I'm on Facebook.
I'm on, you know.
- Talk to me about jumping
around a little bit.
So you break at 16.
Talk to me in those first 24 months,
because there's a lot of
people listening right now
who are destined and are
gonna be big influencers
'cause the way the world works now,
15 minutes of fame and
everyone's got at least 15 fans
and a hell of a lot more now
because the long tail famous.
Just like the music industry
was trying to hold on,
the fame game is everybody's in play.
- It's funny, but you
know, everybody's in play,
but then it's about your contribution.
- Period.
Oh, talent and the
content is the punchline.
The creative is the variable of success.
But everybody's got a shot
in a different way now.
But I was curious, I was just
sitting here listening to you,
I'm like, I don't wanna be selfish,
who was the person that was
real famous that you met
let's say in the first two
years of your fame building,
'cause you hit, that
record came out, boom.
You got some juice,
you were like one of
those first 15, 20 faces
that really mattered when the MTV era
kinda really got going, you know,
Yo! MTV Rap, early days,
like that pocket you were in,
that was 15 names for sure.
Who's the person you met
maybe at the first award show
or in studio, that really
was like, "Oh shit."
Like a Michael Jackson.
- No, I mean, it was Diana
Ross and Michael Jackson.
It was them.
I mean, Diana Ross was the first person
to put me on television.
- Is that right?
- Yeah, Diana Ross had a TV special on ABC
and she gave me my first
break to perform on TV.
- Take me to that story,
how did you find out
you were gonna do that show?
Who called you?
Do you remember?
- I think I'd seen her somewhere
or something like that.
And she was like, "Oh, I
want you to do my show.
I want you to come on and perform."
And I was like, "Okay."
And then somehow she got
with the record company
and I ended up doing it.
And so I have to give Diana-
- Did you have management at that point?
- You know, here's the
funny thing about my career.
I've had a couple of
managers here and there
but the reality is,
Russell managed me for five minutes,
Leo managed me for 10 minutes,
my dad managed me for 15 minutes,
this guy Charles managed
me for maybe 16 minutes.
But you know,
throughout that whole time
I ended up self-managing
myself because for that period
growing up in hip hop,
because there was nobody
who had done it before.
All of the managers were
either former rock managers
or this type of manager or-
- Plus you had it in you.
- Yeah. So I just kinda took the reins.
- It's how I think about myself early on.
People were like, "How
are you getting on there?
Who's doing your PR?"
I'm like, "Me."
- Yeah.
- Knowing you enough, your
entrepreneurial tendencies,
the way you move.
It just makes sense to me.
You were capable of managing yourself.
You probably secretly liked it
'cause you liked the business side of it.
- I do.
- And there you are.
- And then, you know, ultimately
then I got with Chris Lighty at Violator
and Claudine was my day to
day, but Chris was my manager.
But we acted more like
partners, may he rest in peace.
We were more like,
it wasn't like I was calling him like,
"Chris, what should I do?"
It was more like, this
is what I'm thinking,
what you thinking?
You know?
So yeah, I've been,
you know, I kinda been
running my own show for
my whole career.
You know what I mean?
- Being at half-time in your life
because I think that's what
people are very confused
we've got a long way to go.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- What's at this exact second,
what's the thing that's been
really running through
your head in the last
call it six months to a year,
that you're like, I really wanna do this.
- I mean, just this Rock
the Bells platform, man,
building this Rock the Bells platform.
Because this Rock the Bells platform
is something that one day
the youngest kid right now
will be somebody that will
play on Rock the Bells.
Rock the Bells Radio and the
rockthebells.com platform
is not just a place for guys
who started when I started
and are my age now.
It will keep growing, you know.
We will support the Lil' Waynes.
You know, one day everybody that you name
would be playing on Rock the Bells.
So it's like...
I just, like for me, just
giving people a true rendition,
an OG presenting the classic
hip hop space to the world
in a way that is not bitter, is not corny,
we know what year it is,
we're not fucking delusional.
I'm just saying, this is some cool shit
I want you to check it out.
It's like, basically
I'm taking you through
my record collection and my photo album
and my, you know, all the
things I've been through
in my life and showing,
giving you some game.
You know what I mean?
That's what Rock the Bells is like.
So that's really the thing
that I've been focusing on.
And then, you know, doing shows.
- What about some random shit?
You're doing that. I'm excited about that.
I'm glad that people
are hearing about that.
I'm talking like an astronaut,
owning a baseball team,
winning an Academy Awards
thing in your pocket.
- Yeah!
- Some random-ass shit.
You know, one of the things that I try
to really get across to people is,
I know who's listening right now, is,
you're 31, you fucking idiot.
I say that with all love,
you think you're wrapped up,
L, you know this, people
think they're done at 31,
they're like, I'm packing it up.
(LL laughing)
- That's fucking funny.
- That's why I'm glad that you're like, I-
Please everybody understand that reaction.
People think at 31,
'cause they have a kid,
they have a job they don't like,
they have a mortgage.
People are confused out here about age.
So, you know, just knowing
how alive you are at 52,
to me, what I'm curious about is,
what's some real shit
that you think about.
Like for example, for me,
ironically, you did the same thing.
I know, I don't even think, I know,
that I'm gonna make a big-ass
dent in film and television.
From making shows.
I don't think I'm gonna act though,
I'm not fucking scared,
but I just know it.
I genuinely think I'm
gonna have the number one
OTT, Netflix, Hulu, Amazon show, going.
I can feel it, it's been written.
I can taste that shit in my mouth
yet that's not something
I'm showing a whole lot yet.
- Well, it'd be like, and I'm
being totally honest, Gary,
you know...
Like, you know...
See, you know...
When I talk about Rock the Bells,
see most of the time
when people talk about
what they're doing,
they're either like a fucking shill
or they're just,
they're promo-in,
or they're selling.
But you gotta remember, like,
this business that I'm talking about
is the same thing that
I did when I was nine
and started writing when I was 12
and I'm really in this.
And so for me, it's like the
idea that I can build something
that two, three, 400 years from now,
will have the narrative of hip hop...
- Documented.
- Be right. Will be right.
Two, three, four, 500 years from now.
That's what I'm talking about.
I'm not talking about just
making a bunch of money.
I do other things.
I can make money in a
lot of different ways.
And I say that with humility.
I can make money.
- But it's true.
- It's not only about making money.
It's about building something
that means something.
- Let's stay on this topic,
because I wanna enjoy this.
I wanna educate some kids.
How underrated is MC Lyte? Tell 'em.
- Oh my God.
MC Lyte, well first of-
- [Gary] Educate.
- Well, MC Lyte was so good
the first time I heard her on the radio,
I just turned the shit
off because I didn't-
- It made you like, fuck!
- It made me uncomfortable.
And I was like, that's a girl
she shouldn't sound that good.
And I just had to turn it off.
(both laughing)
You know.
It was bugged out.
It was like, I just-
You know, it made me uncomfortable
'cause she's so good.
I ended up writing her
rhyme on "Self-destruction."
We did a song, "Self-destruction."
Scotch tape with a razor
blade tape to your collar.
You know.
♪ Funky fresh, restaurant
press, ready to party ♪
I wrote that for her.
It was like, she is like
her voice, her approach,
people should definitely
dig into MC Lyte's catalog.
- Let's keep playing this
'cause I think it's
getting people pumped about
Rock the Bells,
and well, honestly,
I'm just now having fun
like we're just hanging out.
Give me the same.
We're doing 90 seconds with LL here.
We're gonna play a little game.
What about Heavy D and the Boys?
- Heavy D, unbelievable.
- Give me the history lesson.
Like a funny story or why he's underrated
or how it impacted, play with me here.
- The funniest shit about Hev, look,
I love Hev, may he rest in peace,
he was one of the smoothest
and the best ever.
The thing with Hev is, don't
say a rhyme around Hev,
'cause you might hear some
shit that sounds similar
next week.
- Is that one, is that true?
That's what I need to hear. It's amazing.
- Trust me when I tell you this.
And I love Hev. Hev was my dude.
Hev was the best. Hev was like,
yo, I remember going to
Hev's house in Mount Vernon.
He's still in this house.
The way he flipped his basement
after he came out with
his song, "Mr. Big Stuff"
and all that.
His basement looked like
James Bond should live there.
It was like D, Heavy D.
You walked down that
basement, you're like,
"What the-?"
It was like he took his basement
to a whole 'nother level.
Oh my God.
But Hev was a really good thing,
but it was like, my man Hev,
and my man Flash Gordon,
them two, I won't say nothing around them.
- It might show up on the radio next week.
- It ain't gonna be what you said
but there's gonna be like an offshoot.
(laughing)
- What about Mobb Deep?
- Yo, Prodigy, one of my
favorite MCs and Havoc.
Mobb, unbelievable. You
know what I'm saying?
- What did they-
When they-
- The T-shirt that Prodigy's
wearing in the "Quiet Storm,"
I think it's the "Quiet
Storm" video with Kim.
I wanna say it's that one. I
gave him that T-shirt as a gift
just because I just loved
them, you know what I'm saying?
I have a lot of respect for Mobb Deep
I think the way they represented
Queens was unbelievable.
The way they do represent Queens.
We did a song on my "G.O.A.T" album
called "Killer Queens,"
You know what I'm saying?
♪ And Queens got the vets ♪
It was dope.
And, yo,
the way he wrote,
the way he would make things
rhyme and then not rhyme,
the way he would play with
language, play with words.
♪ Queens, get the money
long time, low cash ♪
You know what I mean?
I mean, he was just...
- I remember I was
like, this guy's clever.
I remember using that word.
- Clever, but he had a way of
sounding authentically tough.
That's not easy to come across.
You could sound angry on a
record, that's one thing.
You could sound angry.
You could sound aggressive.
But to be able to talk
to be calm and really
sound authentically tough,
the only two people to me
that really sound like that
are Prodigy and Rakim.
Where the person is not
they're not yelling, but they
sound aggressive and tough.
- Let's keep this Rock the Bells themed
- [LL] You know what I mean?
- Little fun game, I'm
enjoying this a little bit
for my own self.
What about EPMD?
These are things that I just think
the youngsters don't know.
- Yeah.
- And are all time classic talk,
we're talking all time
classic talk right now,
but I would argue underrated,
which is why I love this.
- Without a doubt.
EPMD is a group that the
kids should check out.
You know, at first,
when they first came out
people used to tease 'em and
say they sounded like Rakim.
Sounded like Eric B and Rakim.
But yo, the beat selection
that Eric Sermon would make,
me and Parish would always
get into conversations
about money and real estate and shit,
and be sitting around
talking about real estate.
We did a record together called "Rampage."
It's a record called "Rampage."
The kids should check out EPMD, "Rampage"
featuring LL Cool J.
It's one of, both of
ours, our best classics.
It's dope.
And they just, they came from Long Island.
EPMD is from Long Island.
So you know, and Long Island,
you know and Rakim is
from Long Island as well.
He's from Wyandanch,
which is right down the
block from North Babylon,
you can literally walk
down his neighborhood
from where I lived in North Babylon.
So it's like-
- A connection.
- It was a vibe. It was a vibe.
EPMD just was so official. So official.
- What about something
that was like a hot minute
that just had a fever pitch to it.
I'd love to get your perspective.
You were in a different part
of your career at this point.
What about Foxy Brown's moment?
- Well, I launched Foxy Brown.
Like, you know, the "I Shot Ya" record
we put Fox, well Chris
and the Trackmasters
put Foxy on the record,
and when I heard it, I didn't object.
I was like, "Yeah, let
her stay. Let us stay."
They didn't do it. They didn't ask.
They just said, "Yo, listen to this."
And I heard it, and I said,
"Go ahead, let her rock."
And she...
- She was fire!
- Solid. Solid.
- That year it just was
like fever pitch with her.
- Solid. Definitely solid,
definitely dope voice.
Definitely like, you know,
tomboyish, but feminine,
it was like she had a good-
She was magic.
You know, she is a very talented act.
You know what I'm saying?
But there's a lot of
talented acts out there now.
Like you think about a Kendrick
and you think about the
way he plays with rhythms,
with his voice.
Even somebody, may he rest
in peace, like Nipsey,
you know, so intelligent.
You know what I'm saying?
So smart. So brilliant.
I know you were close with him.
I saw different times you spoke with him.
I mean, so that's kinda
like that mid generation.
He was very, very special.
What Da Baby's doing now
is very, very clever.
You know the way-
- He just understands the world.
Talk to me about, not to cut off
because I can talk about
Da Baby for a hot minute,
but talk to me about, I like
what you said about MC Lyte,
and I don't wanna run out
of time without asking you,
on that same kick,
what was the track, the
record that you heard
that literally was the
biggest quantum jump for you.
Like from your, you know,
one man's point of view,
you heard it and you were like,
"Oh my God."
Did anything stop you in your track?
- No, no. Yeah. "My Uzi
Weighs a Ton" by Public Enemy.
"My Uzi Weighs a Ton" by Public Enemy.
- Do you remember actually.
- 100% I remember.
I remember shit.
I'm in the parking lot of
White Castle with a Jeep,
with the seat leaned back, with my man.
And that shit came on the fucking,
one of the mixes on
the radio or something.
And that shit, he said, you know,
(imitates hip hop beats)
You know what I mean?
♪ My uzi weighs a ton, hold it now ♪
(imitates hip hop beats)
♪ Get up, get down. ♪
That shit was like,
♪ My uzi weighs a ton ♪
(Gary laughing)
I mean, that shit was like,
yo me and my man was like, what the fuck?
And here's the funny shit.
Rick Rubin had just asked
me a few months later,
"Yo I got this group, Public Enemy,
you know, I'm thinking about putting out.
If I could buy a song from them
would you wanna perform it?"
Then I was like, "I write my own shit."
And I still stand by that
but I kinda should've took that shit.
(both laughing)
That motherfucking record was so cold.
Yo, when I heard "My Uzi Weighs a Ton,"
that shit was like shape-shifting.
I haven't felt that yet.
Like that shit was like,
'cause the way the Bomb Squad,
Hank Shockley and Eric Sadler
the way him, Chuck and all of 'em,
the way they worked with that
and the way they played with technology
because that was the
first time that somebody
really took advantage of the technology,
well, took it to another level.
Marley did it in a different
way with the sampling
but they took it to a whole other level.
Marley kinda
when he was doing some of
those Biz Markie records
those were moments too,
like, "Make the Music with Your Mouth"
and "Rhyming with the-"
Well, "Make the Music with Your Mouth"
and the other record,
yes, y'all, "Nobody Beats the Biz."
Those were kinda like quantum,
they moved the needle
like maybe three points up
but fuck it, Public Enemy was like 100.
You know, that shit was like...
It just...
It was outta control.
And I think that...
Look, that's what you wanna do with art.
That's what you wanna do with music.
That's what you wanna do in your business.
It's just like the dude
who made the 10X book,
about 10X-ing.
That's what they did.
They 10X-ed the creative, the sonics.
They 10X-ed that shit.
- When you think about success,
you've been around a lot of
success in your life now,
in a lot of different genres,
business, Hollywood, music, hip hop,
New York, L.A., the world.
And then all the successful
people that you know
that nobody knows of
whether a real estate
or a lawyer or, right?
For the kids that are listening in
and the kids, I mean a 62 year old
who might've gotten motivated and said,
"You know what? I do have 30
more years to do something.
I'm gonna go do this thing."
What are like...
Now that you're-
You've always been a wise kid
'cause your grandpa passed it on,
you probably just had that in you.
What's like a wise thought
around the common bonds of success?
What are the things that you see
- Well, first of all-
- That you think
really stand out for you
when I set up that question?
- Well, firstly, the first
thing I have to think is,
for that 62 year old,
dreams don't have deadlines.
They gotta understand that.
You know.
- That's fucking huge, man.
- Colonel Sanders started
Kentucky Fried Chicken
when he was 65.
Cornelius Vanderbilt started
his railroad company at 80.
- Sidney Frank, who started
Grey Goose was in his seventies.
- Okay. So you feel me?
And there's a million stories like that.
- You know I'm fucking convinced.
I feel like I'm gonna do a fucking,
I'm gonna drop a fucking bomb
in my 50s, 60s, 70s and 80s.
A new bomb.
- Well, ask how I feel?
That's how I feel.
You know, I'm gonna take the
world and kick it in the ass
and then give it a nice pat on the back.
- Like you did that kid
in the basement of school.
But you know what?
Just like that fight you had,
there's gonna be a scar on your face.
- Well you know, that
comes with the territory.
But what I would say, the
common themes of success,
the common themes of success are
the things that you do in the
valley gets you to the peak
and the things that you do in the peak
can either extend the peak or
take you back to the valley.
So, you know, the peaks
and valley part of it,
it's very important to
understand that part of it.
The other thing I think
is really important
is being able to manage your moods.
Mood management is very important
because your mood a lot
of times, is gonna dictate
not only how you feel about
what you're trying to do,
but how you feel about yourself.
- Do you feel that you stay in the middle?
'Cause I-
- That's the goal.
- That's what I think.
People see my energy and they're confused.
I'm fucking zen as fuck out here.
- Yeah, yeah, but well, enthusiasm is not-
- Is misunderstood.
- Like what did they call-
There's the Stockdale paradox, right?
I'm sure you know about
the Stockdale paradox.
- No, actually, I don't.
- The Stockdale paradox basically says
you're gonna be completely optimistic
but while confronting the brutal facts.
- Yes, that's how I feel. I'm practical.
What I call myself is I'm
practically optimistic.
I know exactly what's happening
but I'm fucking out here
and I'm not delusional.
They're like, Gary, you're too optimistic.
I'm like, What the fuck does that mean?
- Well, I can make it easy for kids.
- I ain't confused out here.
- But we can make it easy for
the youngsters that listening.
I'll make it even easier, Gary's,
it's just like playing a basketball game,
because you down by seven
don't mean you ain't enjoying
yourself and into the game
and playing hard.
- I watched Reggie Miller.
Bro, I watched Reggie
Miller make me fucking cry!
- When he did that? When he scored?
- The game was over. But it wasn't over.
And I don't understand how
people don't understand
how that is.
And I can't get people out of this.
I'm fighting out here like crazy LL,
people, 18, 22, 30, 34, confused as fuck.
- Well, the reason they're
confused is because,
one, they're comparing themselves
to other people too much.
- Yes.
- You cannot.
Life is an odd thing.
You can't treat it like it's a tournament.
It's your life.
And the metrics for success are different.
You know in the Bible there's
that parable of the talents,
so one guy got one talent,
one guy got a couple of talents,
one guy got four times-
- Do you think the world is abundant?
That nobody else's
winnings comes from you?
- 100%
- [Gary] 'Cause that's the one.
- It's not a zero sum game.
See, that's the other part.
- That's why we root for winners.
- 100%
Well that's what I was telling you.
That's what I was telling you.
So it's like, yeah, there is abundance
but you gotta see it that way.
You gotta believe that
it's out there for you
but it becomes a self fulfilling prophecy
because when you believe
it's out there for you,
you go out there and get it.
- [Gary] 100%
- Like I was in the hood,
I mean, when I was in
the hood just growing up,
I would tell dudes like,
"Yo, I'ma be where running 'em is at."
Or, "I'ma get." And they'll be like,
"Come on, man, ain't nothing out here.
Look where they at,
man, look where we at."
Fuck that.
- Yeah. The game don't-
Listen, if you think it's
over, it is actually over.
It is real.
If you think it's over because
your older brother or sister
aren't winning and they told you,
or your parents or the
neighborhood or your cousin
or somebody on the internet.
If you think it's over, I
got some real news for you,
it actually is over.
- And you know what?
To really make it simple,
the bottom line is you
have to believe in yourself
and believe in the beauty of your dreams.
And you have, deep breath,
take a deep breath and go for it.
- Have you seen people who
had the unfortunate situation
of not believing in themselves
because their parents got them-
- 100%
100%
100%. But you know what?
You know, that's a matter of
getting out of your comfort zone.
If your comfort zone, unfortunately,
if the word is unlucky, or
whatever words you wanna use,
if your comfort zone is,
I would say a place where
your default setting
is a place of failure
then you have to be able to
get out of that comfort zone.
- Do you think spending time with people
that are cheering for
you can make that happen?
- I think that can be part of it.
But the other part of it is
you have to be doing the work
that makes that cheering realistic.
You know what I mean?
You could cheer for me.
I could be stretching my legs
standing next to Usain Bolt
and you can be cheering
for me all you want Gary,
but the reality is he's gonna smoke my ass
when we get on that track.
- 100%
- You know what I mean?
So, one, it's about being realistic
about what you're trying to accomplish.
And then two, yes, you wanna
be surrounded by people
who aren't downers.
I remember when Simone
was going through her,
she had a bout with cancer in her leg
and she needed to beat the cancer.
A lady came to our house to visit.
I had just brought Simone
home from the hospital.
Lady came to my house and
she walks in my foyer,
she's crying and shit,
I said, you gotta go.
- Get the fuck outta here.
- You gotta go.
She was.
(laughing)
She was like.
And she was an older lady.
She was like 10 years older.
Yo, you gotta go.
- Surround with offense.
Surround with offense.
- You know what I mean?
- I know what you mean.
- I hate crying and shit
with all that.
That's not helping. All that boo-hoo shit.
That harbors other kinds of emotions.
You full of shit. Go ahead.
You gotta deal with your
shit. You know what I mean?
- Yeah. You're bringing that on.
- So I would tell people, look,
just stay encouraged
and believe in yourself.
Damn.
Look, Michael Jordan
didn't make every shot.
LeBron didn't make every shot.
Look how many championships
LeBron didn't win.
But he didn't stop trying.
And that's why he's phenomenal now.
That's why he's a man that we can respect
and a guy that we can look at as an icon
because he didn't give up.
- Change the script.
You know, we're using
somebody who's iconic.
What about just looking
at life differently?
Maybe you're not destined to be
a tremendous accumulator of money
but maybe you can be a
tremendous human being to others?
- Can I say something to that Gary?
- 'Cause you can.
- People gotta understand
that what it really is
about is knowing your value.
It's not about money only.
Everybody has their place.
Madonna didn't make the same
money that Zuckerberg did.
She still made a contribution
to the world through her art.
- You and I grew up around neighborhoods
where the old man on the
block was the wise one
who helped a lot of kids
not get into dumb shit,
who only made 27,000 a year.
But their contribution was
they genuinely helped 2,700
people have a better life.
And to me that's where
people get fucked up,
they look at the 1% of the 1%
of the 1% of the 1% of the 1%,
and then they're confused out here.
- Because see the thing
I think with people,
what people don't understand is that
if you really know your value
and if you always look
to make a contribution,
your success is gonna come.
It's gonna come.
And however they comes, you know,
look, I always tease a
lot of my rich friends,
and when I say rich friends,
people hear me say that,
and they're like, well, what's rich?
But I'm talking about guys
whose gotta weight like
100X times richer than me,
It's like, dude, a lazy boy,
what can you really do beyond
your chair and your remote?
Like you ain't doing shit.
Only differences is you got a plane.
But other than that, you got the remote
and you're doing this
and you got your lazy
boy, and you're eating.
So let's-
It's not that complicated.
People shouldn't get caught up
in only money, money, money, money.
You're a valuable human
being, regardless of that.
- What's the impact you're making?
- Exactly.
Impact.
- What's the impact?
And what makes you happy?
Like bro, I swear to God,
I literally today, 'cause it's Saturday,
said, "Man, I can't wait
to go garage selling."
- I know that you're
into that. I love that.
You know what I do? You know
what? My pastime is books.
- I love that, which is so foreign to me
'cause I realized I don't
have reading comprehension.
- I love books.
- Good for you.
You can really get down to
read a fucking book, huh?
- Like I read. Like,
dude, that's all I do.
Like when I work out I play audio books
and have music underneath it.
I'm like I'm like a book guy.
Every house I have, every spot,
there's books everywhere.
I'm just always into books.
Books is like-
My idea of a unbelievable day
is just to have a hoodie on, low key,
and just be fucking walking
around a Barnes and Noble,
just staring at books.
Even though I got audio
books and I got a Kindle,
and I got all that shit.
But I'm just saying I like books.
I'm actually,
I named myself LL Cool J
because I'm a fucking nerd.
You know what I mean?
Like books is the thing that turns me on.
That's my shit. Books.
- That's an incredible way to
end this because I gotta run.
I apologize. Thank you
so much L for your time.
- Love.
- If you did not listen
to that last minute
and understand everything
can be wrapped up in it.
If you understand yourself
and you have self-awareness
and you don't understand
that there's a million ways
to play it out here.
This man right here,
winning, impacting happiness.
This man probably read
more books in the last week
than I've read in my life.
- I don't know how many but I
read a lot though, for sure.
- [Gary] Bro, I've read
like eight books in my life.
- But you know what I also do, Gary?
I'll take one book and
read it over and over
for two or three years.
'Cause it's like getting
a black belt in the book.
- I get it.
Listen, everybody does it different.
Here's the bottom line.
Figure your shit out how you do it.
There's a million ways to slice it.
You and I slice it different.
We have commonalities,
we have differences.
Just love yourself and then
you can love everybody else.
L, thank you so much Bro.
- Peace.
Faith in God. Love you man.
Love you G. Peace.
- YouTube watchers,
what's up, it's Gary V.
First of all, thank you so much.
I hope you're doing super
well during these times.
I also wanna ask you, please subscribe,
because my commitment
and exploration of YouTube
is about to explode.
Stories, polls, more
content, more engagement,
more surprise and delight.
This is the time to subscribe.
I hope you consider it.
And I hope I see you soon.